no matter how many Oscars they have in
their display case every actor on the
planet will give a bad performance
sooner or later perhaps a critically
beloved actress will pick up a lousy
screenplay
or maybe a respected star is having a
particularly bad day on set
whatever the reason even the best actors
have given truly awful performances that
will live forever in Hollywood infamy
here we're celebrating some of the worst
Matthew McConaughey The Dark Tower
after years of embarrassing himself with
box-office flops Matthew McConaughey
finally broke free from his rom-com
cursed by sleazing it up in Magic Mike
nailing interstellar and winning Best
Actor for Dallas buyers club with all
that under his belt McConaughey seemed
like the perfect choice to play the
villain in The Dark Tower you were like
a dog fetching a stick over and over but
sadly the 2017 Stephen King adaptation
bombed with critics flopped at the box
office and earned McConaughey some
pretty dark reviews slates Sam Adams
wrote McConaughey's matter-of-fact evil
Fried's more like the indifference of a
check-cashing movie star and Michael
O'Sullivan of the Washington Post said
the actors performance was unlikely to
evoke deathly shivers so much as a
terminal case of the giggles but Alison
will more of BuzzFeed had the best burn
of all when she wrote Matthew
McConaughey offers up what's basically a
more evil version of whatever he's doing
in those Lincoln car commercials 1,800
pounds and do whatever the heck I want I
can respect that Cate Blanchett Indiana
Jones and the Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull screen legend Cate Blanchett won
Best Actress for blue Jasmine wowed
critics with Carol and hand it up to
everyone's delight in thor ragnarok but
hey nobody's perfect something she
learned with Indiana Jones in the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
I want to know
tell me
I'm ready I want to know blanchett came
off as silly and forgettable in a part
that Peter Travers described as a
OneNote villain role with an accent that
conjures up rocky and bullwinkle more
than the desired Red Menace if any other
actors that played the part we wouldn't
care as much but this is Cate Blanchett
she's capable of so much more
eddie redmayne Jupiter ascending in 2015
Eddie Redmayne won the worst Supporting
Actor Razzie for his performance in
Jupiter ascending which ironically hit
theaters just a few days before Redmayne
won his Best Actor Oscar for the theory
of everything but well his performance
as the disabled physicist was flawless
we can't say the same for his turn as
the space Titan who wildly modulates
between murmuring and shouting are great
boys Stephanie Mary of The Washington
Post wrote Redmayne raises his voice to
epic soprano levels when reaming out his
otherworldly lackeys if he's capable of
inflicting damage is to eardrums alone
in an over-the-top movie Redmayne sticks
out as the most outrageous thing in the
film Natalie Portman Star Wars when
Natalie Portman is on her game she's an
absolute phenom that's why she won Best
Actress for Black Swan but of course not
every performance deserves a little cold
statue witnessed the horrors of the Star
Wars prequel trilogy Anakin all I want
is your love love won't save you Padme
maybe it was the corny dialogue or the
zero chemistry she had with her leading
man
whatever the reason Portman was one of
the worst parts of the trilogy which is
really saying something Jake Gyllenhaal
oksha it's fair to say that Jake
Gyllenhaal is one of the best actors in
Hollywood today starring in fan
favorites like stronger Donnie Darko and
end of watch and that's what makes Oak
yesö utterly baffling this Korean sci-fi
flick follows a little girl trying to
rescue an oversized swine from the
clutches of a meat crazed corporation
and the most annoying character she runs
across is Gyllenhaal's in film meet
Jennifer I can't fake these emotions
Dana Stevens of slate wrote there are
performances said to be as broad as a
barn
there's Gyllenhaal's performance and
Kyle Buchanan of vulture said Gyllenhaal
was so flamboyant you can see it from
space Gyllenhaal responded to the
criticism by saying he loved the
reactions and that his performance was
meant to be polarizing well then that's
one more thing he totally nailed Johnny
Depp
Mordecai all right it's been a long time
since anyone called Johnny Depp a great
actor sure he wants and prays for black
mass but for the most part he's been
wearing silly disguises using ridiculous
accents and slumming it in movies like
Alice Through the Looking Glass but once
upon a time Depp was a living breathing
master class and playing weirdos and
screwballs
he even delivered solid performances in
more realistic films like Donnie Brasco
and What's Eating Gilbert Grape
therefore Mordecai perfectly sums up
what's become of Depp's once impressive
career have we taken a wrong turn
arrived on the set of a pornographic
film it's a performance based solely on
physical tics funny voices and
absolutely no substance as film critic
Peter sub Sinskey put it Depp's
performance was on the level of a below
average knock-knock joke
and the Razzies agreed nominating him
for worst actor in 2016
domestic audiences weren't impressed
either as mordecai grossed just 7.6
million at home against a 60 million
dollar budget I make a copy okay
oh thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to